ich glaube es war richtig den beschluss
rückgängig zu machen weil er wäre sehr
schwer vorbereitet gewesen und er hätte
wenig gebracht dass ich war ja von
anfang an skeptisch weil also eine so
kurze ruhephase dann auch noch andere
durch einen samstag wo man einkaufen
kann unterbrochen
das wäre von der wirkung her nicht
ausreichend gewesen von daher ein
riesiger aufwand mit weniger trat sie
haben gleichzeitig damals gesagt ausgang
des beschränkung wären möglicherweise
das sinnvollere mittel sollten die jetzt
kommen was sollte jetzt kommen
befürchten sie jetzt ein oster
armageddon dadurch dass jetzt schärft
verschärfungen zurückgenommen werden
was ist da ihre sorge jetzt mit blick
auf die osterfeiertage ich glaube wir
sind jetzt im sommer damit gut bedient
dass die notbremse gott sei dank der
weiter gilt
aber ich habe natürlich sorge und
appelliere daher an die bevölkerung
nicht zu reißen und also besucher auf
das absolute minimum zu begrenzen
wir werden aber eine weitere also in
eine weitere zunahme der fälle werden
wir beobachten
und weil die fälle zunehmen werden wir
irgendwann etwas machen müssen diese
dritte welle zu brechen das geht nicht
von alleine weg und in dem zusammenhang
glaube ich kommen wir an
ausgangs beschränkungen abends nicht
vorbei alle länder die erfolgreich hier
gegen die dritte welle angekommen sind
anders zum schluss machen müssen für
eine begrenzte zeit wird das auch bei
uns wahrscheinlich nötig seien
wie genau würden sie das vorschlagen da
gibt's ja unterschiedliche konzepte ab
67 oder 9 uhr genau es gibt
unterschiedliche konzepte aber und es
kommen mehr darauf an dass man das
überhaupt macht aber wahrscheinlich
wurde eine ausgangssperre beispielsweise
ab 20 uhr
das würde uns hier weiter bringen ich
weiß aus der vorschlag sehr umstritten
ist auch politisch und auch also in den
fraktionen aber als epidemiologe kann
ich sagen es wird sehr schwer sein an
diesem vorschlag dauer vorbei zu kommen
es sei denn wir hätten schon die testung
in schulen und in betrieben aber das
geht ja nicht so schnell wie wir uns das
gewünscht hätten
nochmal detailfrage zu den
ausgangssperren die dann nur in den
hotspots oder sollten die regional weit
greifen da sein
besser wäre wenn die jetzt zunächst mal
in den hotspots so schnell wie möglich
kämen wenn man damit über die runden
kommt dann ist das eine minimale
beeinträchtigung wird man dann sieht die
fallzahlen sinken immer noch nicht dann
muss man das konzert vielleicht aus den
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren